[Music]
eminem a legend an innovator and a
musical genius over the years people say
that he's lost it and his latest
response to that is with the epic
godzilla it is so perfectly simple the
progression that i'm gonna try and
recreate it out of hair ties my fiance
cabs keeps leaving them all around the
house so i thought i'd gather as many as
i could and put them to good use and
what i've done here is create various
stuff for notes in the shape of
Godzilla's head now all i need to do is
find a flat f and f sharp and then an
octave lower
[Music]
and then with the percussion and
additional melodic sounds I heard so
many different dynamic and unique noises
while creating this Godzilla head so
from the sounds of it it seems as if
I'll be able to create something quite
similar to the original maybe not
exactly anyways let's begin
[Music]
trigger-happy [ __ ] it's black and keep a
hat for the bad meats if that means take
it back so you take it back to fat beats
with the maxi-single look at my rap
sheet what attracts these people is my
gangster buildpack Apache with a catchy
jingle a sec chirps you've barely got a
have fever cheeto
[Music]
don't nobody wanted to figure you get it
anyway forget it you go oh thank you for
watching this week seeing sounds it was
hardcore give me suggestions in the
comments below for any song you would
like me to recreate thank you so much
for the feedback on the previous seeing
sounds and don't forget to Like and
subscribe and turn the notifications
about on other than that I will see you
next
[Music]